a lot of Democrats a lot of progressives
in terms of anti-Semitism on the left
and I always think it's important when
when people even if they've been muddled
and Confused before when they start
coming around um you got to give them
credit so here is CNN's Jake Tapper uh
starting to push on the idea that boy
the left and the Democrats they really
have gone crazy with some of the this
does these last few days have been a
real eye openening period for a lot of
people a lot of Democrats a lot of
progressives in terms of anti-Semitism
on the left
a lot of people who seem more shocked at
dehumanizing language uh used by world
leaders to describe Kamas than what
Kamas actually perpetrated on
Saturday yeah well it's not shocking to
some of us some of us have been saying
for a long time if you believe in
identity politics if you believe that
immutable characteristics are the most
important thing and if you don't have
any basis in biological reality or the
rest of it you might start thinking the
bad guys are the good guys you might
look at a minority of people that have
been programmed and Holocaust across the
globe and go wait a minute how did those
Jews become
successful how did Adam Sandler make all
those movies Jews must be evil and then
you might find yourself at a rally in
Dearborn Michigan waving a Nazi flag so
I want to congratulate Jake and I and I
would encourage Jake to keep pushing
keep trying to show truth on CNN it
ain't going to be
easy